is it time for the Malo investigation to
face an investigation of its own
president Trump's defense lawyer Rudy
Giuliani says Muller should be probed to
see if he helped destroy evidence after
thousands of text messages between Peter
struck and his FBI paramour Lisa Paige
went missing the Department of Justice
claims the politically explosive texts
went missing due to a technical glitch
glitchy glitchy glitchy Francie hates is
a former federal prosecutor and former
DOJ national coordinator of Child
Exploitation and Prevention and she
joins us Francie there's a kind of
credibility issue here because everybody
in some little rinky-dink civil suit in
the local county court knows that you
don't do this kind of stuff how come the
FBI gets away with just vaporizing
important evidence from key figures well
that's a great question mark I don't
know how they get away with it and the
thing that concerns me the most is that
you're talking about text messages that
show bias and as I'm sure you know every
criminal defendant in the courts across
this country are entitled to any
evidence that shows bias by a witness
and struck certainly who would have been
a witness in this case in many cases
showed clear bias and his text messages
with his lover Paige it was wrong for
the Department of Justice to get rid of
these text messages they were the
subject of an OIG investigation already
and it seems to me to be a
constitutional violation that they
cannot provide these text messages to
any current or future defendants well
Peter struck is this very weird figure
because there's like 35,000 FBI
employees but somehow this guy is the
indispensable guys on the Hillary
investigation he's on the Trump
investigation he gets sent to the White
House to stitch up Michael Flynn he gets
flown to London to see Alexander Downer
the Australian High Commissioner so they
can get the goods and Papadopoulos and
then he's sent to the special counsels
office and according to the OIG s report
it's the special counsels office that
reviewed these cellphones
and put them back on factory settings
isn't that corruption in the special
counsels office well it certainly seems
like it could be mark my concern here is
that Bob Muller was a United States
Attorney a presidential appointee he was
the FBI director he knows better than
most people what is relevant to a
potential prosecution and what is
relevant is always exculpate or e
information and that is what is
contained in these text messages and it
is shocking that they deleted them and
it makes you wonder whether it was
purposeful
yeah and that phrase you use exculpatory
information that's actually the
prosecutors can be punished for that no
nobody seems anxious to punish Bob Marla
so maybe Giuliani has a point about
investigating the investigator
another thing Francie while we have you
a new report claims that president
Trump's former attorney Michael Cohen
who famously said he had never been to
Prague may have been there in the summer
of 2016
according to cell phone tower evidence
and that as you know is one of the most
explosive allegations in the various
trumpet details in the Trump dossier is
this is this anything real or is it
hearsay upon hearsay well I think
marking it upon it I think it is hearsay
upon hearsay it reminds me of the very
steel dossier that was the source of
this information in the first place that
has been unverified it is still
unverified to this day and relies upon
mysterious Russian or Eastern European
intelligence sources the same thing that
the FBI and the Department of Justice
asked the FISA Court to rely upon in the
Carter page FISA warrant it is not
reliable information until you show me
American surveillance by Americans that
prove use in Prague I'm not gonna
believe it
so you don't see why this mi6 guy
Christopher Snell a British subject
should be allowed to interfere in the
2016 American election basically I
really don't I think we should leave
that to Americans okay and presumably he
wouldn't he wouldn't actually
if if Cohen had been in Prague
he's now copped a plea with Marla and
the rest of the guys he would presumably
have no incentive not to disclose that
so if he had been there the
investigation would know it wouldn't
they well they would and in fact he has
made no secret of his newfound hatred
for President Trump and has evil ways as
I think he put it and so I think if he
was in Prague and it was part of some
vast conspiracy by the president to
collude with Russia to throw the
election I think he'd be on Twitter
talking about it right now
yeah he does seem to be relatively leaky
about that are we anywhere near a
wrap-up of this investigation
well of course rumors say that Muller
will put out a report in February it's
long overdue in my opinion this
investigation has been going on now for
well over two years I I can't imagine
what it is they're doing now I look
forward to seeing the report but I think
at this point he's just justifying the
millions of dollars that he's been
spending okay for while he's been
spending millions of dollars resetting
iPhones to factory settings it looks
like they've been doing a bit of that
anyway Francie yeah thank you for
explaining all that to us